[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a la crónica de medio
ambiente yo soy María Clara calle
llevamos varias semanas viendo calores
extremos en distintas partes del mundo a
pesar de que ni en el hemisferio sur ni
en el norte todavía es verano los
científicos advierten que marzo fue uno
de los meses más cálidos de los que se
tenga registro y advierten que A
mediados o a finales de 2023 podría
comenzar el fenómeno del niño lo primero
lo que pensamos es en el calor que habrá
pero Qué significa concretamente este
fenómeno veamos
viento y agua Esos son los elementos
centrales para entender los fenómenos
del niño y la niña que ocurren en el
océano Pacífico ecuatorial en La niña
los vientos soplan muy fuerte desde el
este en las costas de América hacia el
oeste en Australia esto mueve el agua
superficial del océano y hace que suban
las corrientes más frescas y ricas en
nutrientes Por eso mientras en países
como Perú son tiempos de mayor pesca del
otro lado los australianos e indonesios
padecen Fuertes lluvias en el niño
ocurre lo contrario los vientos son
débiles y como la superficie del océano
se queda más quieta está más caliente de
lo normal esto provoca que los mares
liberen más calor hacia la atmósfera la
consecuencia el incremento de los
termómetros El Pacífico cambia de un
fenómeno al otro cada cinco o seis años
con la diferencia de que el niño dura
como máximo 12 meses y la niña puede
prolongarse hasta 3 años de hecho la
humanidad acabó de vivir la primera
triple niña del siglo XXI que comenzó en
septiembre de 2020 tuvo un repunte luego
del verano boreal en 2021 y otro más en
diciembre de 2022 hasta febrero de este
año
hemos visto un efecto de enfriamiento en
la temperatura del Pacífico por la niña
y por eso no hemos superado el más alto
calentamiento de todos los tiempos pero
una vez llegue el próximo el niño que es
probable que pase desde finales de este
año hasta el próximo podríamos cruzar el
límite de los 1,5 grados del acuerdo de
París al menos temporalmente
y desde ya se ve La amenaza el de 2023
fue el segundo marzo más caluroso del
que se tenga registro
sabemos entonces que cuando comienza el
fenómeno del niño subirán las
temperaturas pero lo que señala la
ciencia Es que casi todas estas
temporadas han sido peores que las
anteriores para explicarlo vamos a
hablar de estas anomalías de
temperaturas que es en este caso Cuántos
grados hay por encima o por debajo del
promedio del siglo 20 la Gráfica es de
la oficina Nacional de administración
oceánica y atmosférica de Estados Unidos
conocida como el noa por sus siglas en
inglés no solo evidencia como se ha
calentado la tierra en los últimos años
sino que además muestra la tendencia de
que el planeta es cada vez más caliente
Especialmente cuando hay fenómenos del
niño también vemos como cada uno de
estos fenómenos suele ser más fuerte que
el anterior y el pico de calor
registrado hasta ahora fue en 2016 justo
cuando se vivió el niño más fuerte que
ha habido y aquí vemos hacia el final
Cómo se prolongó el fenómeno opuesto el
de la niña Durante los últimos tres años
hay un consenso científico en Cómo se ha
incrementado la temperatura a lo largo
de los años la organización hizo un
resumen de las estadísticas de la NASA
la oficina Med de Reino Unido El Noa
Berkeley y copernicus de la Unión
Europea y aunque difieren por una margen
muy estrecha de la tendencia es la misma
si bien Aún no hay un registro de la
temperatura de 2023 los grados que se
han reportado hasta ahora apuntan a que
este podría ser uno de los años más
calurosos de la historia como lo ven
hacia el final de la Gráfica y así se
está sintiendo ya en varias partes del
mundo la organización estadounidense
hizo este mapa con las zonas de calor
reportadas en marzo de 2023 según
cuántos grados se subió la temperatura
en comparación con el promedio de 1951 a
1980 vemos como los más afectados son
Asia Europa y también el norte de África
al igual que una parte de Sudamérica la
antártida la costa este de Estados
Unidos y el Ártico y lo que la ciencia
demuestra en estudios miles de personas
ya lo están viviendo en Portugal y
España se registraron récords de
alrededor de más de 38 grados Celsius
cuando todavía no llega el verano Y en
la ciudad española de Jaén algunas
personas retomaron un ruego que no se
hacía desde 1949 la procesión para
pedirle a Jesús de Nazareno el abuelo
que haga llover
estamos con una pertina sequía y lo que
se pretende con esta procesión de
rogativa es precisamente invocar al
Señor para que nos ayude y nos salve de
esta sequía
en Asia bangladesh reportó su
temperatura más alta en casi 60 años en
India hubo más de una decena de muertos
por la ola de calor y Tailandia tuvo
reportes desde los 44 hasta los 54
grados Celsius
[Música]
hace un calor inusual este año más calor
que cualquier otro año y hace que mi
trabajo sea más difícil siento que puedo
desmayarme en cualquier momento porque
mi uniforme es muy grueso hace mucho
calor y tengo que barrer un buen tramo
de la carretera
y en la parte sur de América Latina los
más afectados fueron Uruguay chile y
Argentina este último país tuvo la peor
sequía en 60 años incluso teniendo en
cuenta que entre 2022 y 2023 el país
atravesó ocho olas de calor las altas
temperaturas causaron que sus
exportaciones agrícolas puedan caer
cerca de un 30% de este año de acuerdo
con la Organización meteorológica
Mundial por lo que bajaron los cultivos
de trigo y soya hoy nosotros no tenemos
humedad en el suelo para salir a sembrar
ese trigo ese trigo el rendimiento
potencial de ese trigo lo va a explicar
entre un 50 un 60 por ciento la
capacidad de agua útil O sea la
capacidad que tenga el suelo previo a la
siembra y hoy la capacidad de de agua
útil que tiene el suelo es un 5% el
potencial y vemos como todas estas
situaciones se dan cuando el fenómeno
del niño todavía no comienza por lo que
se espera Que las temperaturas suban aún
más así llegamos al final de La Crónica
de medio ambiente pueden ver este y
todos los episodios en France 24.com nos
vemos
[Música]